we're told that epic eats is a perfectly
competitive profit maximizing producer
of stuffed sandwiches and hires workers
in a perfectly competitive labor market
part a says draw side-by-side graphs for
the labor market and for epic eats and
show each of the following so pause this
video and see if you can have a go at it
before we do it together
all right now let's do it together so
we're going to do side by side graphs
one for the market and one for the firm
epic eats so let me do that so
this will be my market
this is my market graph
and so this is going to be quantity of
labor
quantity
of
labor
and then on the vertical axis i have my
wages which you could view as
the price of labor the wage rate and so
this is the market
and then over here i want to do it side
by side this is going to be the firm
this is going to be epic eats
once again i have quantity
quantity
of labor
and i'm going to have
the wage
rate
and this is epic
eats
this is at the firm level
now they want us to show the market wage
and the quantity of workers hired in the
market well to do that we're going to
have to think about the demand for
workers in the market well at a high
wage rate there's not going to be a lot
of labor demanded and then as the wage
goes down
more and more people are going to want
to hire people this is the market
labor
demand curve
demand
curve
and then the supply curve is going to be
upward sloping at a low wage rate not a
lot of people are going to want to give
their labor but then as wages go up
people will more and more people are
likely to enter want to be part of the
labor force so this is going to be the
market
labor
supply
curve
and then we have our equilibrium wage
which they want us to label w sub m
so that is going to be right over here w
sub lowercase m
and then the quantity of workers hired
in the market is going to be capital l
sub sub lowercase m
capital l sub lowercase m so we did this
first part the fact part that focuses on
the market
then they want us to focus on the
marginal factor cost curve labeled mfc
well that's what it's going to cost epic
eats to hire folks and we're dealing
with a it hires in a perfectly
competitive labor market so it's just
going to pay the market wages so let me
do that
so this is going to be the price it pays
for labor
which is
its marginal factor cost curve
m
f
c
just like that so i did the second part
the marginal revenue product labeled mrp
well the way you typically look at it is
for epic eats that it has some marginal
revenue product at a certain quantity
and then as it hires more and more
people intends to have diminishing
returns so typical marginal revenue
product curve looks something like this
so that's mrp did that part
the wage paid by the firm labeled w sub
f and the quantity of workers hired by
the firm labeled l sub f well the wage
paid by the firm that's dictated by the
market wage so we could say that this is
equal to
the market
wage which is equal to the wage paid by
the firm and you could put this over
here the wage paid for the firm is right
over there so we did this first part and
the quantity of workers hired by the
firm what would be rational is is that
they would keep hiring people until the
marginal revenue product is no longer
higher than that marginal cost of hiring
that extra unit of labor so it's right
at that point of intersection and so
that is the quantity of workers hired by
the firm so l
now let's do the next part
it says
assume that there is an increase in the
price of epic eats stuffed sandwiches
in the short run will the wage paid by
epic eats be higher than lower than or
equal to w sub f explained so pause this
video and see if you can answer that
well in the short run epic eats no
matter how much it hires or doesn't hire
it's just going to pay the same wage so
we could say it is going to be equal to
equal
so pay
pay
equal to
w
f
because
operating
in
in perfectly competitive
perfectly competitive
labor market
labor
market in the short run what will happen
to the number of workers hired by epic
eats explain
so in the short run if the wages being
the same but they had a price increase
so that means that the mrp is going to
shift to the right because per unit
they're going to be able to sell it for
more you're going to have a situation
where the mrp switches shifts to the
right or right and up and so you're
going to have mrp
2 this is after the price increase and
notice now we intersect the mfc line at
a higher point and so what will happen
to the number of workers hired
so number
of workers
goes up
because
mrp
shifts
up due
to price increase
price increase
which
causes it
to intersect
intersect your marginal factor cost
curve
mfc
at higher
at higher quantity of labor hired
quantity
of labor
all right now let's do part c
epic eats uses capital and labor in the
production of sandwiches the marginal
product of the last unit of capital used
is four thousand units and the marginal
product of the last unit of labor used
is three thousand
if epic eats minimizes costs and the
rental rate of capital is four 400
what is the wage rate so pause this
video and see if you can answer that
all right so they give us a few things
so the marginal product of the last unit
of capital so we can say marginal
product of the last unit of capital use
cap k for capital even though i know
it's not to confuse ourselves with
something else although you could argue
to use c but we'll use k to ease
confusion so the marginal product of the
last unit of capital is equal to 4 000
units
we know that the marginal product
of the last unit of labor is equal to 3
units
and we could view this right over here
the rental rate of capital you could
view this as the price of capital you
could also view this as the marginal
factor cost of capital but i'll just
call this the price of capital is equal
to 400 dollars
and they want us to figure out the wage
rate so you could view this as the price
of labor is equal to what and they tell
us that it's minimizing costs and one
way to think about it is the number of
units per dollar that the firm gets it
on the margin if they're able to get
more units per dollar by switching by
putting that extra dollar into into
labor versus capital or capital versus
labor they're going to do it so what we
would assume is is that the number of
units per dollar that they're getting at
this point are going to be the same
whether they invest in labor or capital
and so the number of units per dollar
that they're getting from the capital is
the marginal product of the capital
divided by the price of the capital this
is the number of units per dollar and
this needs to be equal to the number of
units per dollar that they're getting
from that last unit of labor so that's
the marginal product of labor so the
units they're getting from labor on the
margin divided by the price of labor on
the margin and then we just solve for
this so this will get us to we're going
to have 4 000 this is 4 000
units
divided by 400
is going to be equal to 3 000 units
3 000 units divided by the price of
labor
so you can manipulate this a little bit
you could divide both sides by 400 so
this is going to be 10 units
per dollar
so let me scroll down a little bit right
over here
so we could this is see yep this is
going to be 10
units already this way 10 units per
dollar is going to be equal to 3 000
units
divided by
the price of labor
and so you just do a little bit of
manipulation multiply both sides by the
price of labor divide both sides by 10
you do a little bit of algebra this gets
you to
300 dollars
per
for the incremental cost of labor so
this is going to get us to the price of
labor is equal to
dollars and you can verify that you
could plug it back in
if you like and we're done